el retorno de Siria a la liga árabe
ocurre después de un mes de intensa
reuniones diplomáticas de alto nivel
entre Arabia saudí Jordania e irán con
Damasco que se han acelerado tras la
normalización de las relaciones entre
riad y Teherán por la mediación de China
a base de la Sad se la responsabilizado
de la cruenta represión contra el
levantamiento Popular de 2011 que
condujo a una cruenta guerra civil que
se ha alargado por más de 12 años y que
ha causado más de medio millón de
Muertos es por eso que los miembros del
organismo pan árabe han readmitido a
Siria con condiciones
ahora que se ha vuelto a normalizar las
relaciones entre los Países Árabes y
Damasco se abren nuevos interrogantes
sobre el futuro de este país en guerra
como es la reconstrucción o el retorno
de los refugiados aquí en el Líbano vive
más de dos millones de refugiados sirios
aunque solamente 800.000 están
registrados por Naciones Unidas la carga
de los refugiados es muy fuerte para el
Líbano y las autoridades están tomando
medidas de presión como es la
deportación a su país de aquellos
refugiados que no estén registrados o no
tengan los documentos legales o el
permiso de trabajo estas nuevas medidas
han llevado a una situación de clima de
tensiones con la comunidad Siria en las
últimas semanas